all right brian yennis in brooklyn brian
thanks
president biden and his team are taking
a victory lap tonight following the
passage of his massive stimulus package
but the crisis at the southern border is
diverting some attention
from that accomplishment white house
correspondent peter ducey
joins us now with the latest good
evening peter good evening brett
president biden had a busy day here at
the white house talking to foreign heads
of state and democrats who work
up the street he just got back to his
house in delaware
at the end of his 51st day in a row
without a formal solo press conference
president biden is trying to stick to
the script like last night in his first
primetime address
if we do all this if we do our part
if we do this together by july the 4th
there's a good chance
you your families and friends will be
able to get together in your backyard
but how big a barbecue
does this white house think will be okay
we're not talking about a july 4th
celebration on the mall
we're not quite there yet this morning
the president met virtually with the
leaders of india japan and australia who
make up the quad
hello everyone i wish we were able to do
this in person but the international
issue president biden isn't talking
about
the flood of migrants through mexico
into texas
people are coming across without being
tested some people are
tested who are positive and then they're
put released to get on a bus and go to
the interior
of the united states and when it comes
to cova testing every border crosser
there's no federal plan
instead there's a proposal for testing
all of these individuals as they
come across but today was about
celebrating the stimulus with many
longtime colleagues of biden including
the speaker of the house
the senate majority leader and the
senate pro tem you know i served a long
time in the united states senate
longer than anybody if i still there at
the time other than pat
and if i were still in the senate i'd be
senator pro temp the president continued
preaching how the stimulus is a uniter
to come out of this moment which we've
been saying a lot of us have been saying
for a long time
more prosperous more united yet couldn't
help leaving a parting shot during a
story about the recovery act he helped
obama
pass for sarah palin brock and i
i spent literally four or five hours a
day for
six months i talked to over 160 mares
probably more than two or three times
every governor saved one who was looking
at from alaska to
russia several dozen democratic
lawmakers joined president biden
at the white house for that celebration
in person it was the largest
in-person event we we have seen him
participate in
since the inauguration even as he warns
the american people the pandemic
is not over and conditions could change
brett peter ducey live on the north lawn
peter thanks
this